amy smolders es una de las pocas jóvenes
neerlandesas que disfrutará del sol
mediterráneo en las próximas horas se
embarcará junto a otros 200 turistas en
un programa piloto que pretende
reactivar el turismo de forma segura
entre países bajos y grecia se siente
muy extraño estar aquí ahora mismo pero
estoy muy emocionada de irme de
vacaciones el destino es la isla de
rodas sin embargo no será una estadía
normal por 275 dólares los viajeros
tendrán acceso a la piscina restaurantes
y todas las instalaciones al interior de
un hotel pero no podrán ni siquiera
salir a la playa se tendrán que
conformar con mirarla desde los balcones
de charca mensual es muy importante que
la gente empiece a venir a nosotros
subir en hostel en toulouse
o dos no es muy agradable para los
turistas estar en un hotel y perder
todas esas cosas magníficas que pueden
hacer en rodas es un paso que vuelve a
poner en marcha el turismo los viajeros
deberán mantener una distancia social de
1,5 metros entre sí
y tendrán que someterse a pruebas de
coronavirus antes durante y después del
viaje algunos negocios que quedan fuera
de los hoteles se muestran escépticos
pero tierno y para eso no creo que
realmente beneficia a las empresas de
restaurantes como el nuestro que están
esperando que la gente venga a comer
el experimento se está haciendo primero
en la hostelería y luego quizás podría
adaptarse a nuestros sectores y de salir
bien la iniciativa podría reactivar al
menos parcialmente un crucial pero
devastado sector turístico griego y es
que no son pocos los neerlandeses que
desean estar cerca de la playa 25.000
personas se inscribieron a este programa
piloto y muchos son los que esperan que
sea exitosos